are you completely comfortable with
breaking the law
we're not breaking the law okay we are
very confident that our measures that
we've announced yesterday are in
compliance with our international law
obligations uh but it's really important
to know that we need to take action the
status quo is unacceptable uh 45 000
people arrived here illegally sometimes
fatally so last year I wasn't small boat
it wasn't illegal it's breaking our laws
to come here without a legal basis
without permission and passing through a
safe country do you acknowledge that Mo
Farah a nine-year-old Mo Farah would
have been booted out of the country when
he was 18. no I don't acknowledge that I
think we have very lawful roots for
people who are genuine victims of
trafficking or modern slavery and for
them to access protection I'm very proud
of that tradition and that culture and
that provision in this country